[Music]
okay everybody so this is
my spoiler review of jupiter's legacy
the new superhero show
on netflix just saying this right now no
spoilers for the comics here
i didn't read the comics i'm not gonna
be talking about the comics here do not
leave spoilers about the comics in the
comments
if you do mention the comics make sure
it's just something we already saw in
the season you can talk about that just
nothing ahead of the timeline so having
said that the show is based on the comic
jupiter's legacy by mark millar who's
done kickass
wanted kingsman so just knowing that you
kind of know what you're kind of signing
up for his signature style
and it's exciting because netflix
desperately needed
some kind of superhero content after
losing all the marvel ip
here and having umbrellas academy really
be
its own thing for that but something
that feels a little more
like what we used to have with daredevil
and ironically
the show original showrunner of this
show is from the original team of
daredevil
stephen s d knight he's written a couple
episodes here
but he actually left a show runner
halfway through due to creative
differences so then
sang kim took over as the showrunner but
it's interesting for netflix because
they have the official rights now to the
miller world here
and his comics so we'll see this is
probably going to start a chain for them
because you know streaming services all
want franchises franchises sell it's
what gets them the big bucks and they
want to rope people in to kind of
like and attach the characters in the
universe it's building which is cool you
know i like that i like characters i
like going back to things for someone i
like
so having said that i'm gonna break down
this review
episode by episode spoilers for the
whole season are in this review so don't
watch any of this review until you've
watched the whole
season so first off i am so happy for
josh
demel here i thought he was perfect as
the utopian
and i was excited to see him actually be
a part that's really interesting and
something that people can kind of get on
board of him as an actor and he
really showed how good of an actor he is
that i didn't even know of because he's
in rom-coms he's in
you know transformers movies you know i
don't know his agent maybe isn't the
best
but this is a good role for him this is
something he needs to be doing right now
and what people want to actually watch
and see him do and see if he can show
off his chops and i think he kills it
here
you also got actress leslie bibb matt
lanter who plays sky fox
and ben daniels who plays walt and i
liked all of these leads here so going
to episode one
by dawn's early light i like the opening
sequence effectively hooks you in as an
audience member because you're seeing
chloe and brandon as kids
and then seeing sheldon come to them as
their father and he's preaching
compassion
service mercy all these things so we're
learning about our main protagonist in
sheldon
but it's giving us a nice exciting intro
to his children and what we're going to
learn about them and it's a nice
lead way into the main present timeline
and it sets up a nice storyline here
that goes throughout the season where
the sun
is very emotional and he has different
philosophy on life than the code
where the father is worried and thinks
he's not ready for these reasons
now we also meet sheldon's wife grace
here as i mentioned leslie bibb who is
lady liberty
and we meet uncle wall it's a very
interesting character
portrayed by ben daniels does a great
job now i'm gonna address the elephant
in the room and that's the makeup
in this show so i think it works for
most
but it's going to stand out the most for
walt and that's an issue because
you don't want to notice it right so if
that's my critique is that
i feel like i'm watching someone in
heavy makeup which you don't want to be
reminded that because it can take you
out
so that's the problem with his makeup
job is like you see it's makeup so i
feel like i'm watching
johnny knoxville and bad grandpa put on
like something over his face that looks
silly it just didn't look right
and i also think they messed it up with
fits where he just didn't look old
enough for what they were going for it's
like they couldn't make up their mind
where it looked like he just had like
gray spray paint in for a second and
then some scenes he doesn't have a beard
a little bit and some he doesn't it just
was messy so not great for that but i
think it worked for sheldon i think it
looked good
it didn't look like it was taking you
out of it but walt was a a big
distraction for that but really
smooth expositional writing here in this
first episode you got a lot of
characters you gotta introduce you gotta
introduce their powers but they do it
at a good pace they don't get bogged
down in exposition
and they kind of show you then more than
tell which is always a good rule of that
but what i was surprised about the show
is that
i actually found the flashbacks the most
interesting part of the show compared to
the present day
timeline i was always intrigued by the
flashbacks and that starts here
seeing pre-power sheldon at this steel
mill and it does a great job of setting
up the differences between him and his
brother walt
and that's kind of laying those seeds
they purposely make you forget about a
bit mid
season to set up the big twist about
walt but that these guys really are
the opposite ends of the table walt is a
classic glass half empty kind of guy
he's a pessimist he's a realist
where sheldon is not sheldon is a man of
faith
and he sees things more black and white
and the show is all about balance right
like that's
right there showing you the balance you
even seen a visual in this episode where
sheldon's on one side of the table
walt's on the other and there's got to
be this gray in between we find and you
see that
with brendan and his sister chloe or
brendan at the beginning of this is
too uptight while chloe's just
completely wild here it hooks you know
and intrigues you with these characters
already because even the dinner scene in
this episode
they're talking about the dad like don't
think i don't know how dad treated us
so it's obviously a murky pass with
sheldon here in that family now where it
starts to get dark
and really started really hooking me in
is in this flashback that sheldon sees
that the stock market crashes
and his father literally jumps off a
roof in front of him
super traumatic moment for our main
character and this will change him
forever
but before we get back to the flashback
what i really liked in this episode
present day scene is
their battle with black star the clone
of black star because it just again was
an effective way
to expositionally just show everyone's
powers and obviously walt has the
sickest powers
out of anyone here with the mind control
and putting black star in a beach and
making these illusions i thought that
was really cool
but you get your payoff in this episode
already because the son's the one who
saves his father's life by
killing black star and breaking the code
so this goes back to the father thinking
he's not ready it proves his point in
his philosophy
and it sets the scene for how these two
characters are going to be on the
opposite
coin in the beginning but like i said
the twist of the episode was black stars
not really black star here
i thought this was a solid opening
episode quick introductions they get you
in the feel of the world pretty fast you
feel like you get it
not confusing and it's hooking enough so
i'm going to give this one an 8.9
one of the shortest episodes like the
finale episode 2 paper and stone this is
only 34 minutes
really deals with what this mystery of
the black star clone is and the
aftermath of brandon's killings
sheldon puts brandon on a hiatus and
this is already going to set up this
divide between
sheldon and grace his wife about how
they're even handling their kids so
my first worrisome acting in the show
actually comes
with when we learn more about fitz and
petra the actress of peach we get very
little of her
but uh she was a little over the top
something
just wasn't right there every line she
had very little in the whole season but
it just
wasn't really working for me i did like
this scene known present day in this
episode with
chloe and sheldon is when chloe says
only way
out of the loop is for me to stop being
me or you to stop being you just
that constant conflict a lot of family
members have with each other where no
one's actually making the choice
to change but what i'm talking about in
these flashbacks i thought were so
interesting especially in the beginning
of the show
that walt was the one who was being
truthful about who their father really
was and what he was doing with the money
and saying that the article was accurate
that
grace had written and this was hard for
sheldon to process but this was also
setting up
how they both handle things differently
and how they see the world differently
and it will really set up our main
villain versus our main protagonist
what makes you like sheldon though is
like it's hard for him to fire these
people at the mill
when walt's like you gotta do this and i
really liked sheldon here
reflecting on what happened with his
father killing himself and feeling guilt
for it again it makes you just like him
more and it's really
fascinating to me and honestly i was
just blown away at this point by josh
jamel's acting i think he hid it note
for note perfectly and he's so
likable which is important for a role
like this and i think it makes him even
more castable in shows like this like
you know
i'm sure marvel and dc are watching this
like come on this guy's got the chops
and i like to cut between the funeral of
the superheroes we lost
and in the past it's a father's funeral
and you see sheldon
bugs out here at the funeral in the past
collapses and i love the line
really don't know someone until they die
really referring to his father but you
see they developed this grace
sheldon conflict where she's slowly
going away from the code here and
pushing against sheldon
if there weren't exceptions to killing
in the code we would be buried next to
brandon's
friends so i thought that was a really
good powerful line and again
it's stuff pushing our protagonists to
change right because that's the thing he
needs to change in himself that's set up
from the beginning here he needs to
open his mind a bit so i like they bring
in this mystery
the weirdness to it that in the past
sheldon's waking up in the hospital he's
having visions of his father
yelling at him and he's seeing the
island i thought this was really
just intriguing and just hooking you in
more especially in episode two and i
liked how they're taking their time with
the backstory of how they get the powers
it's kind of the thing you're just
looking forward to
and excited to see okay what's going to
be the big moment how did this really
happen
and i think that only works on a netflix
show that it's bingeable that you can
get away with how long it took them
to get to that so i think that was the
right choice for a show that you knew
you could just go from episode episode
it has the bingey feel having these
quick cl fingers at the end of each
episode and getting right into it in the
next episode but kind of can take their
time with origin
if this was week to week i think i would
have lost my patience pretty quickly
with the flashbacks but i'm gonna give
this episode an 8.8
to me just as good as the opener and it
keeps that momentum going so episode
three
painting the clouds with sunshine now we
get into my really favorite character of
the show
which is sky fox aka george and we go to
the flashback with him
and the actor here matt lanter is
brilliant
as george really kills it and the dude
loves his eggs he loves his number eggs
i thought that was intriguing
i still want to know more about that it
was cool right away you get little hints
at things like you see those drawings
sheldon had
all those designs were the designs on
his suit but they developed really well
george and sheldon's relationship and
that they have more of a
almost healthy brotherly type
relationship than walt and sheldon they
see eye to eye more
in the beginning in the sense and where
they both are similar sheldon and george
is that
they do have a belief in something and
they're more
optimistic about things in the sense of
oh yeah these visions can have meaning
there is something to this
he did believe in sheldon where walt
didn't they bond over the loss of
parents
and george says a great line life
happened and then it stopped and it's
interesting because
he's snapping sheldon out of his funk
but at the same time brings him right
back in by bringing the images up again
and actually
believing in the images because then
sheldon gets obsessed again i like
though they introduced young hutch here
in present day in the same episode as we
got to know
the older hutch it's cool he doesn't
really have powers but he has this
rod which i thought was going to be
stupid but it actually worked really
well they used it in creative
interesting ways like
how he just kills that guy through the
heart with it and then he sends
that character lucy to shark infested
water so that was pretty cool and you
really notice it here in this episode
but i really like
they decided to go with aspect ratio
changing in present day and flashback
and that flashback
time was standard ratio and current day
is more cinematic in the widescreen
format just to subconsciously put your
head where you need to be and we get a
little cliffhanger here adding more
mystery that hutch
is like almost there dad almost there so
he's trying to find his dad
at this point i'm still really liking it
characters are central focus here
pace is moving great and each scene has
a purpose and i'm just loving the
flashbacks i'm like i like the present
day
but i'm like obsessed with the show
that's the flashbacks
now episode four all the devils are here
this is gonna be more chloe centered
episode the open of this episode was a
little cringy and
everything here felt a little forced and
i think it's more cringy too because
like people really don't like
teen angst stories if he angst it up too
much it's hard to sympathize with the
character but i did like that they
showed she was used by this guy for her
father something she struggles with and
of course would make her resent her
father even more i like when she said to
this guy nick
first thing he's gonna ask you is if he
can take a punch and then she hits him i
thought that was awesome but we see with
sheldon in the flashback
like he still does in present day he
puts being hero first and taking care of
others in the world first but he
actually ignores important things in his
presence
life in the process and that happens
here when he is on the phone with jane
making amends and then he quickly gets
distracted but that good deed he did
led him to a girl telling him about the
windmill he's looking for so it's almost
like destiny for this guy to find this
island now
i think this is the peak of the show the
best part of the show was these
flashbacks
of sheldon finding this creepy house at
the windmill and meeting this old man
and i am tasting the hair dye on my
beard as we speak
but he's like out in the sea when i was
in the navy
i encounter this mystery the sea comes
alive the water always finds you and
then sheldon's got this ringing going on
in his head
and this guy freaking shoots himself and
it's cool he found these skeletons in
the basement and that they end up being
visions of his friends so it's
just leading him more down this rabbit
hole of like okay i need to find this
place i also like in present day how
they tied chloe
to where we saw her in the storyline
with young hutch and they hit her by the
car
she gets dropped by her agent she's
using walter white's crystal meth here
and she has this overdose and there's
this cliffhanger for a second like oh my
god is hutch just gonna watch you there
die
like walter white did but he doesn't
thank god this also was a standout
episode for cinematography especially
that's seen in the
cabin it's just consistent so far good
weight to all these characters and it's
relatable to people
mostly again i don't know how everyone's
gonna react to the chloe thing i've been
feeling the chloe character is gonna be
the least popular
but we'll see so i'm gonna give this one
still an 8.9 just really good
so episode five what's the use this is
where we lean into really getting to
know sheldon's mindset and he's in this
therapy scene in present day
a lot of people say it's cliche we see
this in so many superhero shows in
particular
just recently in falcon the winter
soldier as well but i think it really
works here and they only do it for one
episode it would have been annoying if
they did it the whole season
i like his monologue here though he's
like what's the point of doing good if
no one perceives it that way and he was
going to reverse the sins of his father
by doing everything else
the opposite way so it really does some
heavy character work here for sheldon we
got okay now we know why he's
like this and with sheldon again some
good lines from the therapist or he's
like you're hoping to stay alive in the
minds of the people you love the way
your father couldn't so it's interesting
too where sheldon now in present day has
led to
hutch jr and they're talking about
george and george is like the way my mom
put it is that you guys turned your back
on sky fox so it makes you wonder even
from where we ended the season
we're going to learn more about what
really happened when they separated and
really who's the bad guy there now we
get more reminders and hints about where
walt's really gonna end up when he talks
to george
when we're in the process of sheldon in
the flashbacks recruiting everybody to
go on this journey and walt was the
hardest for him to recruit
and walt even says to george you're
feeding his delusions so was it really
george who was super anti-sheldon yeah
george's anti-code but it doesn't mean
he was totally this
evil person and they did a really good
job at not really showing you
too much of walt's total moral compass
they held that
the character of jane though kind of was
silly and just a whimper i mean she was
upset she was not in sheldon's vision
and
just kind of disappeared and they really
didn't with sheldon's story in the past
do a great job of really showing
why he completely flipped over to grace
i know she had that powerful line to him
on the boat that he doesn't have to kill
but i i don't know it just didn't really
click
now it's interesting because we get to
the midpoint of the show here
and we get some really important lines
because they're really what the show's
kind of hit mathematically where the
therapist says reality always wins out
no matter how profoundly we rail against
it
so you look at walt he's the realist
and you look at sheldon where he's
always you know
rallying against it and he's like you
exist in a world of creation black and
white good versus evil but don't allow
for the way the world really is
how people live in it shades of gray
this is thematically all about religion
too and how people
view religion and the debate about good
versus evil and gray in the world it's
something you hear therapists say too
but why it's the big midpoint line is
because it's what our character sheldon
is going to have to realize himself
fully
to grow as a character by the end of the
season and it's a cool twist here i mean
this therapist
is actually a criminal sheldon had
locked away who tried to kill him for 20
years i hope they go
more into that next season but this one
was a little slower on the flashback
side you had a good twist and
some cool stuff here i'm gonna give this
one 8.5 okay so episode six
cover her face this was the first
episode that was the first drop in
quality for me and where the writing
starts get a little choppy here is when
grace says to fitz of course i see it my
son took a life
i mean he turned against everything we
taught him and he took a life
i don't know why she keeps saying that
it's like this repetitive weird
loop that the writing has there it just
felt weird it sounds like i'm over
exaggerating but if you actually watch
the scene you can tell the actress even
was uncomfortable saying it and
where it comes a little problematic is
even in the flashbacks
we start to get a little too reflective
here there's a lot of we need to be
better than them
it's in the present as well and it's
that walking dead issue that walking
dead fell into where everyone's just
talking about the themes of the show and
reflecting on everything
that's where it gets too telly and it
can really bore an audience just show it
and show it to people's actions so this
is where
the first one is started to zone out a
bit and it's concerning because
it's the first episode written by the
new showrunner now what i also thought
was strange is this character
richard that shows up on the boat the
last person sheldon's waiting for for
his vision
but i thought he just really was useless
and he's in some big significant moments
with the characters we
all i think got enough time maybe fitz
didn't get enough time but i think he'll
get more
but we still got some time in the more
richard just came in last minute so even
when like
they actually get to the island and they
get to jupiter
and he sees the person he cares about
who the hell is that like i don't even
know this guy you know so i thought his
character
kind of was pointless and you could have
had without him i also had an issue in
present day with this episode where
when grace finds janna's dead because
she was one convincing her not to break
the code
and she didn't she feels guilt for this
but this did not hit
hard enough for me that she would even
care this much about janet dying because
i don't buy it be enough for grace to
want to change her philosophy just on
this alone
and that the relationship of grace and
janna wasn't built up enough for us an
audience to really
care as much as grace did but the grace
baryon fight was pretty cool
beat some bloody here so we see in the
end of this episode the flashback
big reveals that they find this island
things ramp up here because you got
that stop watch going his father stopped
watching what you hear a lot in the back
of round of this
show in general and grace has that huge
line to sheldon killing is never the
answer
clearly her philosophy will change on
that but this one i'm gonna give an
eight
still good but definitely losing some
momentum here in steam
episode 7 omnispro uno but we meet
raiku who is now a contract killer who
has the powers
like walt like a psychic and is actually
his daughter she's a really cool intro
where she's got like this hawkeye ronin
and avengers end game intro
i thought that was sick and i thought it
was cool how walt stops her mind
mid-fight but this is where we also got
maybe an unnatural change of brandon's
character
when he's talking to chloe and sounding
more like his dad i don't think we got
enough time with brandon here and why he
was
changing his philosophy to not wanting
to kill anymore because he was so
kind of on that but i did like where
grace was finally calling sheldon out
about the code she's like it's not
1930 anymore we've adjusted the times
basically again a theme a lot of people
can relate to today and
and calling him out that it's really for
him like his therapist was saying and
it's that
you know selfishness stubbornness
disguised as like a moral high ground
for sheldon we all know people like that
but you'll see brandon actually
sounding like his father says to petra
who's out of the union here
it's never about the easy way out the
code he's talking about it's what
separates us
from everyone else it sounds very rick
in the walking dead that theme where
you know if we change and kill people
now how are we not different from the
bad people but it's interesting looking
back now at when
walt shows up to black star in prison
and black stars like
sky fox knew how silly the code was and
he says if i were in the union
i would expose sheldon for the fraud he
is that's kind of hinting at
something actually walt agrees with and
hears here but it was cool to see walt
making black star's mind forget how to
breathe that was really cool but we see
walt kind of sets up
his little trickery here in staging and
trying to frame sky fox for his master
plan
trapping himself in this black star
clones brain that he actually made
but even when they get to this island i
don't know something about it was just
too slow in the flashback and just
getting to what this big moment the
powers are and what's frustrating about
is when you get to that
it's kind of a letdown like it
wasn't something amazing or something
you couldn't predict it was like oh yeah
it's what you kind of thought was going
to happen that they find this
mystical power and that's it and there
was a really problematic writing here
really corny cheesy stuff that just
started getting into the show
disappointingly
at this point like when fitz says to
them when they're all walking who would
you choose if he could see someone again
and everyone just goes on through their
answer here it's only written
to make sure that they can pull off the
last scene where they see
who they would choose to see again
really forced and when grace is
connecting the islands trying to pit
them against each other again it's been
so dumb before so this even felt
a little too familiar and not original
and it got so cheesy too where they just
realized like
they have to put their differences aside
to bond and when he sheldon puts his
hand on walt's shoulder and then him and
george and all the makeup of each other
come on
but you see those little hints again
that's really significant that when walt
first put his hand there it did not
light up
and that he clearly already has a bad
sense about him
but like i said this big reveal that
wasn't big and how they got their powers
it just missed the wow moment that was
kind of let up again i did like the slow
play of to find the origins but the
payoff really wasn't there for me this
episode not supposed to drag this whole
sequence with this black star clone on
the table just need to move quicker so
this episode was okay to me but
it was definitely not great i'm gonna
give it a 7.5 but let's go to the big
finale
called how it all ends only 35 minutes
here was a little disappointing as well
just short and already only eight
episode season now i really like the
visuals here of walt
in this world and i'm bringing in lady
liberty here to verse sky fox
and i like the visual we had of like
walt in a moment looks like he's
han solo and carbonite and they trick
you well here because
just with the writing with chloe saying
at one point that
sky fox is like the world's greatest
supervillains you're like oh man he
really is and then
it's set up for this episode to view him
that way and that when he's fighting
walt
and he's fighting lady liberty he looks
like this big villain and
he's really sick character i like the
old gunny brought in here but i like it
setting up that we see that
sheldon resents hutch for being such a
close family member and
him breaking the code and becoming who
he thinks is this monster and it makes
sense for his character why he
make the code so valuable then so that
his kids wouldn't become
like sky fox in his eyes but it's gonna
be just to see next season how sheldon
will eventually have to process this
person he's judging and monsters
actually his own brother but some weak
action here i don't think
it really was great with hutch jr here
showing up
in china and he's in this like tank with
no oxygen and then chloe saves them it's
like two seconds the fight you know
i want to see more of that i want to see
more of chloe using her powers something
more interesting there just felt
way too short and not fulfilling but i
really thought the episode
hit really well here going back and
forth between this battle with
brandon and utopian versus black star
and then cutting between lady liberty
walt and skye fox and
what was so significant and worked
really well to me at first
with the black star battle was because
he was taking our protagonist
putting him at this highest point of
conflict his decision he has to make of
whether to kill or not at his worst
moment because he's about to kill his
son in front of him it's testing him
fully as a character and this is his
moment to change and grow
but it was just a little annoying that
petra just comes in and saves the day
here
stopping that moment of growth or just
what we thought we would have got to by
now maybe
some kind of change a little bit for a
whole season arc
and it really didn't happen but look his
eyes lit up it looks like he was going
to save him as he said he was going to
but the real
change comes from brandon here who
doesn't kill blackstar where he had
killed
the clone version earlier so he did have
his transformation but like i said i
don't think it was totally earned
throughout the season but in this stuff
the standout of this episode was the
stuff in this
simulation world and i love how it
looked with the red
laser lines coming down it was just sick
but you see looking back at it it's
interesting because at first it feels
really weird how they edited how they
got out of it walt
and grace and you're like wait that was
strange it just ended
but it makes sense because they didn't
want to show you yet that walt was the
one
who really had control of the situation
got them out of there
just to show his cryptic message to
grace which is really dark where
she sees a vision of sheldon and brandon
dead with sky fox behind it so he's
framing sky fox even more but
when you think about it it's really
walt's goal which is really dark
and i like how this was the big twister
going that we got a big twist at the end
of the season to make you excited for
the next season and that it was walt and
i mean it's believable to me i think
they
did enough like i said where they didn't
show too much of walt's moral compass
they hinted at things
we didn't know fully what this
present-day walt was actually like
and they distracted you with sky fox
misleading you and i thought it worked
it was a good misdirect and it's true to
walt's character from the past
and how he is this pessimist completely
different than sheldon what i did think
was weird though in present day where
sheldon
is talking to walt and sheldon says that
he's afraid now he's losing brandon but
it seemed like to me brandon was
closest he's ever been here to sheldon
because he was getting what his dad's
been preaching so i thought that was
strange
i'm confused by that but you see how
cold walt is you see how when raiku
talks to him how
she's saying you know he wasn't there
for her as a father he didn't
treat the wife right you know he's just
a cold dude and he's even
talking with his own daughter about
paying her off and see it's funny though
because
he says to walt you can trust me but he
knows he's not trustable and he knows
his daughter
isn't either because she has his blood
and that's why he kills her
because he knows he can't even pair off
in my money to keep quiet what he's
really up to
really dark stuff but it was just a
shocking moment to see him kill his own
daughter i thought that worked really
really well
so i'm gonna give the finale a 9.1
thought it was exciting and it said
enough exciting stuff
for the next season where this might go
but look overall i think i'll give the
season
an 8.8 i really enjoyed it i think i was
surprised how much i enjoyed it and i
think it's been a while for a netflix
show for me to
not get really bored during it i thought
most of this i really enjoyed and for
some of its flaws it had it was mostly
good
and i think that goes down to sheldon's
character being great
and josh jamel just killing it and his
likability so
it makes me still intrigued by these
characters and what's going to happen
with them
in the next season again i think most of
these actors were great
at least the leads really held their
weight down and there's a lot of mystery
in world building here
i can't wait to see what's to come i
think it's a success but i'm really
interested to see how this will be
received by critics and by fans will
this be a hit for netflix because
netflix needs more franchises it needs
more hits to keep
up with these disney pluses of the world
so we'll see
let me know down below what you thought
of this season
i want to hear every thought you have i
read every comment try to respond as
many as i can
please make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss one of my reviews i do a
bunch of tv shows movies and celebrity
interviews as well so you're gonna want
to check that out
and please follow me at steve barley
show on twitter instagram for more of me
and i'll see you next time